[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes welcome back to the morning toast
happy Thursday
happy Thursday this week has felt long
at times but ultimately very short it's
what Cameron said on southern charm last
night
the days are long but the years are
short it's true each day was difficult
this week but the week just really flew
by yesterday I thought it was Tuesday I
know told me was website and it was just
such a lovely surprised I love being
surprised in a positive way like I'm
always like oh it was a Friday no it's
Tuesday
you know it's Monday I never think it's
earlier than it is I always think it's
later than it is so yesterday was truly
just a blessing it was we recorded the
snapshot yesterday the first of its kind
every time I had a great time I felt as
though it was so informative we got
everything off of our chest snatchler
how did you feel I thought it went great
I literally felt like the biggest weight
lifted off of my shoulder he has done
honestly I don't think we stopped like I
don't think we breathed for an hour like
no just didn't stop and people were like
you spoke about The Bachelor so much on
the toaster like what did you even leave
for the snatcher it's like that we could
have gone on for another hour so there
endless amounts of content don't ever
worry you guys what's crazy as we spoke
about it for an hour without taking a
breath and we actually forgot to mention
Gigi and Tyler see ya because we've
literally beat that dead horse on this
show that mentioned have a like no she's
not a paradise wheels I say but we're
tiny the snatcher recaps all bachelor
related news and we were number two in
the iTunes Store we never made it to
number one unfortunately but you know
what
beggars can't be choosers so head over
to iTunes we're also on Spotify now
subscribe to the snatchler that's
natural with the sea a lot of people
were upset that they're not with a C T
in the snatch are people like it should
be s n ACH yes smash alors then it would
be French and honestly it would make me
do this delicious a national or sneak
smash nor Senesh Lord what do you think
are you protein
i'm protein me too yeah you putting a
sack you put in the snatch in sadler
yeah I don't even remember did we do
yesterday in the episode did we talk
about the name no we meant you and I
don't want to talk I don't feel the need
to explain my choices no but some people
are like to know that Zak means vagina
yes it's mention it I did triple
entendre also I know that yesterday
officially declared it to be winter
because I was done sharing my legs but I
just couldn't find anything to wear
today except for this
like my safe outfit so just ignore me
I'm gonna be freezing outside today
seeing as how it's winter and I'm
wearing a rubber exciting stuff um I
feel like I'm preparing myself to have
like a hot girl winter like I always
grind in the summer and shine in the
winter which is just not what most
people do but it works for me March the
beat around drum girl I know but it's
like god forbid I ever looked like
semi-decent but I feel great like no
we're not in the bathing suit by the way
sorry sorry you're not a model okay
can't be we can't all be like you so
true nude world's first comedic popstar
and model she does it all she truly does
how was your evening afternoon did you
watch southern charm I watched southern
charm my evening was nice I went to
dinner with my friend lovely we're doing
Morandi because oh what a pity no once
ran into Andy Cohen I would say it's
also a 45-minute car to the West Village
Museum of course he always eats there he
talks about in his book it's like his
favorite restaurant I think he lives
near there I actually was not impressed
I've never been but you want to know why
I have PTSD from it because the
restaurants called
morandi and when I was in eighth grade
our music teacher who are anymore Randy
Mora in Hebrew means teacher so her name
was more and then her first name was
Randy and she didn't give me a solo in
the eighth grade Zimmer Yan like I truly
never forgot it
so mm-hmm I can't go there I understand
actually when I pulled up I was like
Maureen Maureen Dee and I she was never
my Maura so it was it was funny that's
funny that she was so famous in her
house for not giving me a solo yeah I
actually did like the biggest thing ever
and I ordered an eggplant parm because I
got a confused with eggplant rollatini I
thought it was gonna be is it more or
less the same no it was like heavily
breaded oh it was like probably the most
that anything I could have possibly the
most fattening day would have been
chicken parm I guess I'm not even would
we pasta but I I think we all now have
started intermittent fasting so that's
why I like fell come from selectively
ordering a big meal um because you need
to be able to get there until noon I'm
having some wine I'm one tonight
I'm intermittent fasting if when we walk
outside of this show and there's no ice
cream truck like every other day like
you never know if the ice cream truck is
gonna be there there usually is so if
it's there I'm not fasting but if it's
not it's not telling me to stop eating
okay
Anderson but that's how a lot of people
attribute their weight loss to is
intermittent fasting well now I only
started doing it because like you guys
just set on
you were gonna do it Margot says so I
was like okay I'll do it too and then
actually today I was looking it up to
see the pros and cons in like what you
the benefit and I realized that I think
I've been intermittent fasting like my
entire life it's not like that crazy
it's not that crazy I don't really eat
breakfast I never eat before the toast
so now I'll just have like an extra hour
where I don't eat the only thing that
might be helpful is like when I cut
myself off at 9:00 I guess sometimes I
would have a late night snack while
watching southern charm while watching
southern charm which we will be
recapping yes I have a lot of thoughts
okay can you save them because they also
caught up on the last two episodes
before that can you hold onto your that
also we just hung out with the entire
cast and that's like this is where I
feel torn because life is imitating
arting you're having a Teddy Mellencamp
syndrome what's up where you hate
someone on TV but you love them in real
life
yes TNS yeah that's all you guys truly
I'm plagued I'm play consider me play
I'm also plagued with it for Blake
Worthman I have to luckily yeah EMS what
does this hand-forged Mellencamp
syndrome it's so real
it's so real anyways I feel as though
maybe it could be time I don't know it's
time we can always dip in and out of our
personalized you know it's so funny do
you ever save people's names in your
phone like like you maybe know like part
of their first name and then you like
make their last name the place where you
met them yeah of course so I just got a
text message from someone whose name I
like totally saved weird Lane and I
really don't know who it is it out yeah
just we're doing a lag show it's morning
kosai show it's dirty Rock live but I've
actually recently restarted 30 rock for
like the 18 hundredths time it's such a
blessing I learned an interesting story
in Howard Stern's book in his interview
with Tina Facebook you've gotta read
this book or I could just keep telling
you D and you have it I do can I take it
for my weekend away yeah it's huge and
it's so heavy so I'm not playing I'm not
flying so okay well in his industry
interview with Tina Fey she was saying
he was asking like do people always come
up to you at your kids school like
you're Tina Fey but blah blah and she
was like yeah she was like actually the
way that I got this the idea for 30 rock
it's like some kid had a script tape to
him I guess his parent taped it to the
kid at her kids school
and he ran up to her to give her the
script in that it was the idea for 30
rock Wow mm-hmm that person's rich now
yeah well I mean they were rich if
they're going to Tina Fey's kids that's
so true you know but it's like you'd
think a Tina Fey school there's some
discretion like you can't just be like
thirsting at the PTA no but if you're
gonna be thirsting at the PTA it's cool
to do it in a creative way
no of course and one in which I
appreciate you to pay for actually
reading it I would have thrown it
directly in the trash what if one of the
dogs at the dog park ran up to you with
your next hit song dun dun dun
so that was like I bet Tina Fey gets so
many like scripts in her email yeah that
like she wouldn't give the one from her
kids school even the time of day but she
did no but it came in a different way I
feel like that's always what happens to
us you get so much in your email that
it's all starts with the same but when
someone approaches you in a new and
unique way makes you remember exactly
okay well I feel as though you let me
know I feel as though it's time to
deliver the past life stories that you
need is it I feel as though it is it is
time to deliver the fast side story is
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast now it is time and I don't want to
sidetrack us too much because as you
know the show is also called the morning
tangent but I would be like literally so
upset by you know I would actually like
if I tend to let everyone know all of
our listeners know take your time that
today's episode is brought to you by
function of beauty one of our newer
brands one that I'm truly loving as
someone who's actually started to age
and I only know that I'm getting old
because my hair is like stopping growing
and stopping shining but that has
stopped
I love function of eating because we all
know the frustration bottles and bottles
piling up in your bathroom each one
falsely promoting a miracle solution
that only kind of work but what if there
was just one shampoo that could truly do
it all we don't all have the same hair
so why should we all use the same
shampoo conditioner great question
function unity brings you shampoos and
conditioners that are customized and
individually filled just for you
of course you go online and take a quiz
because it's nice to be seen and it's
especially nice to be heard and function
of beauty totally understands that most
drugstore brands only address a single
concern either volume eyes or strengthen
but with function of beauty you can
choose up to five hair goals to add to
your for formulation function of beauty
individually formulates every bottle
based on your hair type your hair goals
and your preferences so I chose no
fragrance because I find that that
fragrance like is up in my nose all day
and I don't enjoy it I love the
fragrance some see you could select your
color and fragrance or you can opt for a
dye free and a frame
for you the products are personalized
with your name on it which is super cute
and let's bend know like hey I paid
extra for this so get the [ __ ] out scram
function of UT never uses sulfates
parabens for the lates
thing if you can't pronounce yeah which
is exactly why they shouldn't be in your
hair okay I have over 20,000 five-star
customer reviews and Counting I really
enjoy it it feels cool to have something
with my name on it
also I'd stop using drugstore brands for
my hair like two years ago and this has
probably been the best solution just for
the shine I feel like my hair is dull
now it's even think about getting a
gloss but I do feel as though my shine
has returned it has you can receive 20%
off your first order of function of
beauty to redeem had to function of
beauty calm / toast take the air profile
quiz go to function of beauty calm /
toast toas tea to get 20% off your
custom formula and also the shampoo and
conditioner sizes are enormous which is
like when I get a small shampoo Bob I'm
like who do you think this is for a baby
like a ton of hair I put like two
handfuls worth of shampoo in my hair
every night like I need big jugs I got
the jugs and I need big jugs I hear you
man love it
okay and that's the tape first story
ladies your ship is coming in Taylor
Swift on the cover of Vogue September
issue as called by your girl he was
gonna say someone was like the toast
called a time and you know I'd love to
take credit for things but I remember
thinking I don't actually remember
saying that um I said it we were talking
about the September issue because I
believe Megan Marco was like writing
something for British or described to
her issue so I was like who do you think
is gonna be on American and then I
realized Taylor Swift because she's in
press mode and she's a long relationship
with Vogue but we're in her and Carly
we're on the cover that was like such a
crazy time yes she sits on the board of
the Met Gala oh yes you know she's in it
too in it so this is a no-brainer it's a
no-brainer but I have to say I'm a
little disappointed because when you the
cover star is usually on though due to
73 questions but Taylor has already done
it so she did this video where she like
had to ask Anna eight questions like I
don't give a [ __ ] about what Anna is
favorite character from Katz's like you
know need me I need quite eight
questions asked to Taylor Swift agreed
also Taylor Swift has been doing a lot
of interviewing these days and that's
like thing she's coming for our jobs
she's coming for our jobs but it's like
it's so smart because then she gets to
do press but doesn't have to answer any
questions what sounds like who's this
song about you know I guess it's
actually genius
is this song about oh my god then made
me watch bill de blasio
like doing an interview last night
because it's like his first presidential
interview like interview and he like was
trying to be like I guess it was
actually kind of like a smart like
politician because he's like super far
left anyone on on Fox News and it was
literally the dumbest interview like he
was being asked questions and he was
just asked in the question right back it
was actually a genius move because he
didn't have to answer anything is like
well what do you think she Americans
have guns in that like he was just
literally taking the question and asking
it back to the interviewer it's like no
that's your job to answer so overall do
you think it went well um I do actually
know it was it didn't go well cuz he
didn't answer anything but I had a lot
of respect for him for going on a
program where like they probably didn't
want him and like they never would have
agreed on anything I'm like that's my
partisanship at its finest and I
appreciate that yeah going into the
Lions Den yeah it's like on Howard
Stern's book no but it was actually
really interesting he was dying to get
Hillary Clinton on his show and he was
like had this whole plan of questions he
was gonna ask her like really humanize
her whatever he bring his whole lot that
in The Washington Post like Hillary
Clinton please come on Mike Hillary he's
not political he doesn't he he really
just like likes to get to know people
and he's on Ted Trump on his show like
since the 90s so like we really wanted
Hillary on and she never wound up coming
on and he waited look all of the he was
like I heard she likes gardening I
bought this whole gardening basket for
her
he never around upsetting at her and she
never mind I'm coming on but I just
thought it was really interesting that
is interested she didn't pull so I have
more respect for I didn't do politics I
thought that he did no he does not
because he says like his views always
change and that's the worst thing I'm
like when a host or a personality like
you have to have like clear to stick to
you have to stick to what you say you
have to have like clear opinions on
everything whether you're right or wrong
like you just have to like the table
which is sometimes always struggle with
yeah but being wishy-washy
yeah it's whatever the times change in
your opinions do change yeah but like
when something happens on The Bachelor
and then we're firmly oh of course of
course but the Baxters like a thankfully
a little less serious in politics oh for
sure but I think it's the same premise
yeah and the middle is the place to be
you guys the middle is the place to be
so I said yeah that's what we spoke
about on the stature yeah
she's on the cover of Vogue looking
great looking great looking like it
Barry David Bowie asked she was giving
me like Queen vibes also you take Queen
to the concert at Madison Square Garden
last night like they're a great band but
like how dare they go on tour that
Freddie been doing it for a year and
then it would pay for that great 30,000
people at Madison Square but like and
they had like videos of of Freddie
Mercury but it's like it's like going
room five without Adam Levine you know a
smaller scale but in the past what
they've done is they have this one
person who can imitate Freddie Mercury's
voice like to a tee and he's sung for
Freddie Mercury and that person actually
collabed on the movie soundtrack they
spliced him in also Adam Lambert Lambert
has subbed in as Freddie Mercury loved
it so they get creative with it and what
they should all be out of work like they
are still a great band they have so many
hit songs like I would love to jam out
to clean up Madison Square Garden I love
Adam libel goes like honestly if someone
was like we're seeing a queen cover band
like want to come I'd be like okay oh by
the way meet you because you would pay
$10 to see a cover that's true that's
all I'm saying okay but I would like
ensure he's actually loved Adam Lambert
and I appreciate the fact that he is
like really stuck around
in recent years and like he's always
gotten creative like American Idol
didn't do for him what he did for other
people like he just stuck around like
he's like stuck to who he was like doing
like he loves Broadway he loves show
tunes like and he's really just like
come out on top like he went on Glee a
genius genius pyramid speaking of Glee
on next Wednesday right we have Kevin
McHale and Jenna Ushkowitz running their
new podcast which is like it's like a
best friend podcast I guess that's like
why they wanted to come on our show
which I'd like the Gleek and me is
totally dying also on Monday we at a
more judge who's never been on our show
before we've never had a real house of
ours Tammy I'm like and of all the ones
like I am at Amherst and like since day
one and you used to yell at me about it
like I firmly believe she's a
professional housewife and I'm super
excited to talk to her oh that's really
exciting
I never notice you've never had an
Orange County yeah they don't they don't
come to New York a lot what happens if
you pass someone said they don't really
do podcasts anymore because they were
all just like going off-book and that's
what they were talking about it like at
every reunion yeah so but I guess
they're back to it now so tomorrow I
mean next week is gonna be a premium
last week yeah notably in Taylor Swift's
September issue they asked her about the
stirrers hello I haven't read I really
want to try read the article or I don't
want to read it on my phone
like I wanted to really enjoy it cuz
like we get so little from her agreed
but this was like the headline that's
now like being pulled but and she
appears to admit that she didn't attempt
to buy the map because she said it was
either investing in my past or my or my
and other artists future and I chose the
future great so wait how does that mean
that that she didn't I tend to invest in
her past like she chose that she was
given the option but she's admitting
that she turned it down like that deal
where they wanted that was her choice we
already knew yeah okay
yeah we we knew sort of and then she
talks about like they came in Kanye
stuff what is she okay you know I want
it I want to read it and enjoy it I
realize that it's my job to recap but I
just like we never get a team out too
early this morning like I haven't had a
chance to like I can't even watched a
video it was like four minutes it was
truly so boring and it was just like if
you had to talk watch me and it's like
Anna Wintour has like a million dogs
that she names after characters from
tequila Mockingbird so it would be
another character it was literally so
boring like I met is so that it's just I
got in a little bit imagine Jackie
imagining the editor of a magazine and
having like the biggest talent in the
world and finding a way to make it make
a piece of content about you that's
honestly like that's like selfish levels
that only I can attain I know maybe you
have more in common with Adam Ant or
that I thought yeah check out my hair oh
my god I okay like no shade but I do
happen to think like that is like the
ugliest hairstyle ever oh I had one in
which only one person in the world could
pull off Olivia Pope oh no I don't wait
or cuz she's so scary I think it's cool
I like it for her I don't know that I
would never cut my hair like that right
now but like for her I think it's I like
how she loved but Olivia Cocos and like
people who are copying it'll be a couple
it's a little longer yeah and she
doesn't have blood veins right oh yeah
yeah okay
next story is deeply disturbing I almost
don't want to talk about it but you
insisted LAPD is investigating a
youtuber who appeared to abuse her dog
video okay this youtuber who and by the
way we have a rule here where we don't
like to talk about people like who
aren't famous because like why are we
even doing that and this girl isn't
absolutely nobody she is like 6,000
Instagram followers and her YouTube is
not prominent but she considers herself
a YouTube star to the point where she
you know had to make a video of her
playing with her dog there's like a
trend going around
it's like you put saran wrap on your
doorway so your dog doesn't see it and
like you you chase the dog and like you
jump over it and like the dog is
confused because like he can't get
around the saran wrap it is incredibly
stupid and she was trying to do that and
I guess like she had like a ton of
footage and some of it included her
abusing her dog and she accidentally
included like three scenes where so I
would say she's a youtuber but she's a
terrible one like she doesn't watch a
video before it goes up right and she
literally kicks the dog slams the dog
down on the floor spits on the dog and
screams at him and she this is so
upsetting it's I watched it twice and it
is literally it was all I could think
about last night it was so upsetting and
then she would least a statement being
like I'm not an abuser blah blah blah
you know Joba winds are super hard to
train and very expensive so it's like
okay you can't handle the expenses of a
Doberman but it's better off a banner
from dogs like leave it in a shelter
because you are worse the worst person
in the world and it's like if you know
Dobermans like he's 75 pounds like he
came and attacked me so like I have to
shove him down like sue also had to spit
on him right like he learns nothing from
from a drop of water waste water like
truly cash it does him more than three
hundred and thirty thousand subscribers
on YouTube yeah I guess that's why um
she's even spoken up but like I wonder I
really hope her youtube count is coming
down I hope her YouTube with your hand
is going down and I hope the LAPD are
investigating like there's no explaining
away they are investigating and I hope
you know justice is served
there's no explaining her behavior like
I understand dogs need to be trained you
know he jumps up but like he was jumping
up in like a loving way if you can't
handle like a loving jump from your dog
don't have a dog and don't have a big
dog no oh he was totally he wasn't
attacking her he was like hey MA yeah
and she's like also like you can't
handle hey MA don't be a mom I do
understand like I have seen trainers who
they don't hit but they pat the nose of
a dog okay like not not have not what
we're told not everyone's favorite
technique but is effective like slamming
like I can't believe she didn't break
she must have broken the dog's bone like
slamming it down so hard multiple times
and I know the reason why I wanted to
talk about this is like I feel like
youtubers and like internet people who
like go through like scandals like they
get talked about so much for far less
and it's like people are talking about
this but not on the scale that they
shouldn't because like I know she's not
known but like this is evil it's because
she's not that known and it's like
honestly by talking about her we're
making her more famous and like that's
the last thing she deserves right so
that's why I didn't want to talk about
it um but if her statement was just such
[ __ ] she's like I'm not an abuser
even though there's full proof of me I
be an abuser and you know gentlemen's
are like super hard/expensive she trains
like we're working on your name a
trainer it's like you should never have
gotten a dog if you can't handle the
responsibility
how long has she even had this dog I
don't know if the dogs are expensive
like they require a lot and if you can't
supplement that no no shade just don't
do it no if you just have to have a kind
heart and like you'll be able to figure
it out
also oh thank you wait Jackie heart like
the premise of someone pranking their
dog is so [ __ ] up - so [ __ ] over -
but like watching her being an actress
under the video like can you tacky you
know it's like you only see how like you
doesn't it like your dog and like you I
thought you're a youtuber now you're an
actress like get the [ __ ] out of here
nobody's like 1004 shekel and hide
that's what like it was so eerie to
watch it's like the [ __ ] are you doing
no but it's like you really don't know
anyone like you follow people and
YouTube like they snapchat their whole
lives like you don't know that they
secretly beat their dogs no and like the
premise of YouTube is like real people
in their real lives like being relatable
and it's like we didn't come here to
watch you act like I'll put on a film
thank you yeah and I want to see a great
editor such a great call the duplicitous
tiss she is so two-faced she was so
[ __ ] T basic literally she may not be
two people [ __ ]
and maybe two people but I'm not
two-faced yes she's [ __ ] both she's a
nut job
like I just I want her name to be
smeared I can't explain it like if you
heard an animal like you should never be
able to get a job to have any friends or
be happy yet let alone like have a
modicum of YouTube fame and I'm just
gonna be quite lucrative
yes and but she can't afford a trainer
right I just want to put it out there
like I will like I am open and down to
foster this dog like if they take him
away like give him to me I don't love
Dobermans like I'll figure it out SIA
would love him Theo and him oh my god
match made in heaven
Chucky be on him Enoshima they would be
smashing lord
anyways I'm really glad that we also
haven't said
thereby not making her more famous good
call honestly though video it's it's so
upset don't watch the video it's deeply
upsetting agreed but I felt a pop
craving they just like posted it and you
know me I love a good click babe
yeah and then you send to toss it ok
like yeah I didn't watch it it's so I
was I was gonna show it to Ben but he
literally like when it comes to animals
he couldn't handle like he was on the
dope a cha sight making me watch this
video of these guys who saved a deer who
was like in a frozen lake and brought
them back to his house and then like set
him free and Ben was actually crying
like tears of joy so I just couldn't
show it to him I didn't have the heart
to ruin his day and his life I
understand I can't even look at this
[ __ ] right now like she's a pretty girl
but she's so ugly she's girl inside
you know what someone's inside ugliness
literally radiates out yeah [ __ ] I hate
this girl so much ok 15 years I can't
talk about it she better hope she never
won Emmys won't have a host this year
just like the Oscars the news was
announced by Fox CEO Charlie Collier on
Wednesday at the TCA Press store in
Beverly Hills the move follows the
Oscars going hostess last February after
planned host Kevin Hart dropped out amid
controversy Oscar's ratings actually
improved without a host by roughly 12%
and received a fair degree of critical
acclaim one critic asked Holly or if the
Academy Awards ratings uptick inspired
Fox to dump the Emmys host to quote
obviously that was a piece of
information and it did you very well but
I think it's a pretty unique year for
some of America's favorite shows and it
was the right thing to do it's like sad
that you know hosting has gone the way
of brick-and-mortar like this is this is
bad news for us no it's like with each
award show which eat with each host help
me with my analogy and okay with teach
the award show a hostess turns over in
their grave yeah how's that it's I can't
I hear what you're trying to little
morbid yeah yeah it's a little Morgan
whatever this is sad like the hosting
industry is already so competitive now
they're making less and less
opportunities for hosts to shine and
devastating but whatever as a viewer I'm
looking forward to like not having to
like sit through those painful
monologues
yeah it did get a little crazy at time
and it was like a thankless job you
barely get paid every which way like
crickets in the audience of all the
hosts who have coming on of like Emmys
Oscars who do you think did the best job
I have a I can I give like a top three
Shore Hugh Jackman
yeah Tony what did he host Toni Egger no
and he hosted the Oscars came out like
and he's like a whole song and dancing
it was great okay um Seth MacFarlane he
loves to do a song and dance yeah and so
this set makes art whether that was
gonna be my answer and changed oh but
Kelly Carson I've been Billboard Music
Awards I'm talking about like top tier
like Colleen James Corden yeah okay good
I agree I agree yeah those are like safe
bets I filled when do you feel it so um
Brad Paisley and Carrie Underwood are
going to retire from their job of CMA
host never never until their ass like
until they fade and it seems like the
next year it's like Kelsea Ballerini
Thomas Rhett because they host CMA
Fassett like I'll be the next show
second yeah it'll be interesting that
works for me we do kind of like that
they have the same thing every year meet
you it's nice like some people like they
take a risk on and they suck yeah we're
like maybe it takes you more than a year
to get into your groove it's like yeah
it's a lot of pressure
yeah I just think like I don't want to
toot my own horn but I think it'd be a
great house for like a meat for the
Chili's like I sing dance host yeah I
think we can I feel like my model I
would love Ben honestly they should have
like Lea Michele host even though she's
like not on Broadway now according did a
great job this year the important does a
great job in everything that James
Corden is so multi-talented
he's a host he's a singer he's truly a
comedian like he really does it all he's
now in cats he's an actor he really is a
multi talent and he's like the type of
person who like was destined to become
famous like I bet when he was like
growing up all those parents friends
like you're gonna be famous yeah almost
like tap telling me imma grab things
were like get away nerd and of course he
had no friends yeah yeah for sure well
speaking of posting news enews is moving
from LA to New York to become a morning
show sounds familiar
okay the changes are due for 2020 as the
cable air expands its news footprint
with additional daily and weekly
programs E's flagship news program is
getting a new home in more way
than one enews which has aired at 7 p.m.
eastern Pacific time from Los Angeles
for most of its life will transition to
a morning show in 2020
it also will switch coast and originate
from NBC's 30 rock studios in New York
the changes to the show are part of a
larger revamp of the kaehler's
entertainment news programming which
includes several new shows set to debut
in 2020 and an expansion of the
late-night show nightly pop to four
nights a week congratulations Morgan
Stewart so deserved agree the move of
the flagship show two mornings is
designed to give pop culture fans a dose
of news at the start of the day and
offer insight on unfolding stories after
the morning toast has already talked
about it so we can copy their opinions
quote the e news footprint is
unparalleled and our growth continues
with this investment in more edgy
comedic personality driven linear
programming oh my god that again is
paralleled yeah it's not edgy comedic
personality driven wow this is linear
see I mean I'm sorry okay I'm gonna
wouldn't say linear I'm gonna speak on
this from the two sides of my brain one
is just someone you know who works in
the industry I think this is really
smart like enews definitely needs some
morning programming like they're a
little scattered right now how those
like any news that night but daily pop
is such a great show and like they're
really trying to spin on that so I think
having a new york-based slate of morning
programs is so good I don't know how
it's gonna work because pop culture fans
have jobs and they're not streaming live
on Facebook or anything dle pop does but
if it's all on cable I don't really
foresee how the viewership is gonna work
but I think this is a great idea I do
hope that they expand you know into some
some pre-existing shows like honestly as
much as we like hate on any news like
this this slate of programming with me
for us me for us and I don't like the
dream job I think that's like every
person who is a host dream job whatever
you say that I always think of this
first day in one of my classes at NYU
where everyone's like who's your role
model like that their dream job is like
what you want and like literally every
single girl I just see an event cyclic
I'm really inspired by her like she's so
great like she has the best job at red
carpet it was like literally the least
creative answer and everyone said it
that's so not true
it is true but it's also because E news
is really the only program of its kind
right it's the only it's allogram that's
not news II yeah like pop culture news
program that's taken seriously as a news
program like Bravo doesn't have that
any other competing even that looks like
a real TV student like a news studio
with the screens and yes the
correspondent I guess like Access
Hollywood and extra would be similar but
for some reason they just haven't like
resonated as like as much with our
generations yeah and also because I
think they're always swapping out hosts
and it's all different but like Giuliana
Rancic has been on e news Jason forever
yep
so I think this is cool obviously I'm a
big fan of morning shows maybe someone
any news finally just watch Morning
Glory and was inspired right that is
usually what happened that's usually
what happens so the great film I mean
we're morning show hosts who support
other morning show host
that's exactly right sister and even if
they don't pick up the toasts which I'm
just saying they 100% should we are here
to support our fellow hosts yeah also
they're announcing other shows like
another morning show called
top of the morning which will be a panel
show dissecting buzz worthy
entertainment stories but it also just
sat like at the same time there's not
like that much pop culture news that you
need back to back to back to back eight
to twelve programs yes so now they're
gonna have four morning shows and
they're gonna be repeating the same news
every day but I guess it's just like a
difference of opinions maybe but it's
like it's not that deep right like how
are you gonna differentiate it looks at
each show every once in a while we get
like a James Charles Tati and we can all
and a college in the student scandal
that we can talk about and we're blue in
the face but most days it's like Taylor
Swift on the cover and vote today it's
like a very slow news day like we're 30
minutes in and we're on the fourth story
already right yeah but that's just the
way the news team works that's just the
way the cookie crumbles
Wow is that for Morning Glory no that's
right every saw my tea also a great film
about a host snitch would you go tell
those hooligans outside we're filming a
live show those children you're the
snatcher Margo be empowered it's just oh
my god screaming in the morning Thank
You Margo I don't know counts you know
it's like this is the thing it's a
metaphor like nobody respects us you
know like guys we're talking you can see
the big on-air sign outside no they
don't they don't thank you Mario well
again just a great day for hosting that
means morning shows are being taken
seriously and that's really one as a
morning show host that's all you can ask
for an entertainment morning shows are
being taken seriously and I know I think
we might
the pioneers right do you think that
they like took a look at our like
situation see that it's working we were
like a proof-of-concept do you think we
were a conversation in this at all
or are we like so conceited that we
think everything's about us okay here's
the thing it's their eyes rose you know
oh please yeah whatever
so here's the thing it's either it has
nothing to do with us or it's completely
about us Jackie I know and it's hard for
me to ever see a situation not being
about myself but this one really is
making it extra hard because I just feel
as though you know we we are out here
doing this for like two years two years
now and someone somewhere has realized
that there is an interest for pop
culture in the morning where like I
would say arbitrarily like we are a
success right yeah yeah so and I know
for a fact that lots of people at the
e-news office in LA do watch the toast
regularly especially when we talk about
them hey guys you talked to your boss
about us yeah I love what you're doing
yeah
but other than that like but taking
myself out of the equation I think this
is a good move free and very smart they
have really been like behind as a
network in terms of evolving like Bravo
rebranded like Bravo really like knows
who they are as a network and like he is
constantly just like making and
cancelling shows like they really can't
get their [ __ ] together but I feel like
in the last year with even busy tonight
it wasn't successful like pop nightly
pop lady gang busy too like they're
really going more towards like female
centric like hosted shows yacht like
scripted like scripted is kind of like
passe and Bravo nobody does it better
than Bravo uh I do agree they're not
they're no longer competing in the space
the same space as Bravo
yes like they were trying with like all
their reality shows it's not them this
this late of programming definitely
seems more newsy and more their vibe
also like for a morning show you have to
be in New York or I'll see if I wake up
so early in LA like even daily pop is on
at noon in New York and they have to get
there at like 5:00 a.m. when I was on
daily pop I woke up at 6:00 a.m. and I'm
like I watched jelly pop in New York
after the toast like why am i up yeah
like if they moved here they would
living the dream just isn't me yeah it's
more expensive but 30 Rock Studios is
swanky prestigious as hell imagine just
like rolling in every day 30 rock for
your job daily pop is gonna stay there
but if they want anything earlier like
they'd be working at three for a yeah
but they do need a show based in LA it's
a ha it's like a pop culture show
everything happens in LA exactly agree
I'm excited to see how this unfolds me
too then the final story as the beyond
meet influences that we are subway is
testing out a meatless sub here's why
I'm sorry that you told me about oh the
kid with the loo sorry I forgot hold on
I think we should do that one instead
okay but I do want to talk about subway
having um because really now almost
every major food chain oh wait what was
the story subway is having like an
impossible meet beyond meat sub a cold
cut the sandwich start selling the
product mean with beyond meats plant
based protein at 685 restaurants in the
US and Canada next month the be on
meatball marinara so that sounds [ __ ]
delicious
oh you have to try it yeah do you think
this is gonna affect the Brad smell
Oh Brad why smell okay God yeah it's
like I can only get it deliver because I
can't walk in there no totally but I can
walk in there because it's it's worth
braving that awful smell for a fountain
soda they've the best found the other
day
also toasters around the world when we
had the conversation about the subway
smell the restaurant not the train they
were shocked because I know there's no
controversy they overwhelmingly love it
and we were on here saying like our
sister Olivia's a freak because she
loves it but I think the world that the
universal decision is that the world
loves to smell I think we're we're split
there's I don't think the two types of
people in this world people who love the
smell of people who hate this now if we
had a live show on E right now we could
utilize a pole and say head to w WH LG
TV do you love or hate the smell of
Subway let's just make this episode of
pitch yeah and then we would find out
and then Sykes and like we wouldn't be
just sitting here like asking questions
into a void you know what I mean
right okay so that's exciting it's just
fun to let everyone know you know I'm
gonna do it just because I really do
want to know the answer I'm just gonna
do a poll on the morning shows Instagram
do you love or hate the smell of Subway
restaurants it's 5050 in the comments
well we're gonna put it to a poll this
height I've always thought that it
smelled like ass yes
I hate the smell of Subway restaurants I
feel like I have to say restaurants cuz
everybody it's the smell of the subway
train right it's confusing they too need
a rebrand oh they are rebranding the
subway train no subway oh I think it
already began yes okay now for actual
fifth and final story that I thought was
pertinent to this show at the end of the
show let's um we'll go to the poll Daily
Mail reports
jool pods almost killed me an 18 year
old college students lung collapse after
vaping for a year damn mm-hmm chants
amorita a rising freshman at Florida
International University in Miami was at
death's door last week as a result of
the device he thought was safe
on average Chan's faked about one jewel
pod every two days that's a lot by the
way that's roughly the equivalent of 10
cigarettes worth of nicotine a day the
FDA does not cap nicotine content for
cigarettes or vapes contents of other
chemicals vary from product to product
and everyone's tolerances vary for
nicotine are different so it's not clear
how much is too much
it has Alton leave it also has recently
announced plans to add more substance to
his list of toxins ecig and cigarette
makers must disclose as well as to
regulate nicotine content what okay so
this kid's chance I keep posted pictures
out of his lung that are just committed
he was like bowling with his girlfriend
he was having major chest pains he
thought he was having a heart attack and
he went to the hospital and like a team
of seven surgeons had to operate on him
his lung had collapsed from jülich so
viciously for a year OMG which is like
really scary no scary as [ __ ] yeah
because also I feel as though joules
have only been around for so long so
it's hard to know what the long-term
effects are right and yes they make the
argument that they are safer than
cigarettes because they don't have those
carcinogens that result as from the
tobacco and cigarettes but it's still
not good right clearly but no one could
say what's what could happen because
there was no actual proof yes so this is
just and I'm sure now as time goes by
we'll be hearing of more cases of Joule
related injuries and
diseases um and if you look at the
pictures of his lung it they had like
black dots on them which it's not good
no no bueno I hope he's feeling better I
hope he quits the jewel and maybe might
inspire some others to do so yeah so
it's not without its risks
terrible terrible hope it's okay yeah
ruining I think it bowling date it
sounds like he is okay but it was it was
not a good situation for him sad so she
could bright future first-year college
student yes nobody takes it seriously I
need people who have like really scary
like he had a real emergency his lung
Dan I hate when people have really scary
medical emergencies like go back to
living their lives you narrow down right
yeah like you have a second chance at
life bro yeah use it if he hadn't gotten
to the hospital fast enough he would
have died at least nine other teenager
teenagers in Wisconsin were hospitalized
last week US regulators are demanding
Jule to disclose the chemicals in its
pods demanding agreed yes also can they
make organic pods like that have 100
chemicals they know naked why people
really like to jewel just for the
activity of Julie like they don't meet
the teenagers don't realize that there's
nicotine and they don't want the
nicotine can they make nicotine free
Jules yeah because they make 5% nicotine
and they make 3% nicotine so you can
you're representing you like water yeah
just an oral fixation right like that's
it and they like the kids like to blow
o's and like speak cool with smoke in
their mouth so like if we just want to
let these asshats do that like make it
just like powder I don't know by the way
we are the asshat says no I know I'm
rethinking the jewel well there's also
been I haven't tried the CBD jewel pod
someone gave me one once it was like not
in the package and it was like so shady
looking like I just couldn't I couldn't
yeah I actually want to get it though
but I've yet to see like a legitimate
one yeah I feel like every time I see
one it's like isn't some back alley it's
in the back of someone's desk you like
yes sure this is definitely better
very sad the jewel company wants to add
nicotine because then it's addictive and
people will keep doing it but like but
there's something about the oral and
like just like the fixations people just
like to have their jewel in their hand
because it's like a safe thing for them
and like just to like puff whatever so
like I would be interested to see if
they made a product none all their
products one product that was nicotine
free yeah I think
could sleep better at night yeah and I
think jewel is doing well as a company
very profitable they're like worth
billions of dollars Philip Morris has
bought staking them so like I think they
can shelf their greed for a second me to
the grave of God so I'm just like a
healthy pot I think the problem is that
no matter what it is you're inhaling it
so it's still like an inhalation but no
but it's hot and there's lots of like
medicinal positive qualities and the
inhalation is not a problem and lungs
aren't collapsing from smoking the
chemicals are what's there laughing the
lot yeah so if they take out the
chemicals maybe like some aloe vera pods
yeah or like some yes ellipta spot some
bergamot ha vicks vapor rub pods when
you're sick that's a good idea right
idea I shouldn't have said it out loud
you should talk no it would be vexing
Jule and you should just like a
consultant such a good idea such a good
idea okay well we felt as though it was
our responsibility to warn you this side
effects and next up we're gonna live and
make a wish I know buddy's lungs would
collapse anymore and I wish for some
different healthier jewel pod
alternatives and that the jewel honchos
well you know see that this is what we
need I'll be greedy um okay let's talk
about southern charm okay I caught up on
a bunch of episodes
um I've really turned a corner on Eliza
Thornberry because I just love the
culture and history she's bringing to
the show like her family's so impressive
and when they did the Fox ID without
killing any foxes I stand when they were
doing the fox hunt I felt like I was
watching a period mm-hmm it was and I
thought it was just so impressive and I
think they brought her onto the show
because of the loss of Thomas Ravenel
and his bridge so they brought in a new
bridge because southern charm is cool
and it's you know they're all southern
but like that historic element is what
makes the show interesting interesting
and gravitas full of gravitas I feel
like we need a fox hunt every season and
that was really then a poem ass chick to
see I loved how they took the scent of
the Fox rub down the tree so that after
killing a fox all those dogs running out
of the thing like I could have died I
just know that they take care of their
animals you know yeah it was
really just like so fun to watch I wish
you know me and Chelsea had stayed on
the horses because I thought that would
be so funny yeah considering it wasn't a
real hunt they were they could have done
it but all the people like following
around on the trolley like drinking beer
like that looked so much fun so much fun
[ __ ] Craig in his babushka okay I
haven't really turned a corner on Craig
good I love him I love Craig he always
finds himself like in the weeds on these
fights but when you watch it in
hindsight he's not wrong and I think
everything he said last night and as a
related to Madison and Austin was
completely fair like I will still be
your friend if you want to date her if
she [ __ ] you over again like I'm done
supporting your relationship yeah I just
really like like Austin Madison and I
don't know why they can't get it
together I think I hope that this last
time does work out because when we saw
them I think they were together
but they were also being dodgy about it
but maybe that's just because it's a
Schuyler yeah but I want to talk about
the chlamydia of it all is that was that
the disease
yes because it was a bombshell from last
week that poured into this week and I
did I do actually think Madison feels
really bad about it like Shep was being
so [ __ ] annoying that she she just
wanted to hurt him like she just wanted
to say something and she ended up
hurting Danni which was not cool cuz
Danni has been like a decent friend her
but the way that both Shep and Danni
reacted like makes me think it's true oh
I don't think anyone's questioning the
validity of the claim yuko really yeah I
mean she's like and I don't expect Danni
to a minute and I don't think she's a
liar for not but did we know previously
that Shep and Danny had ever hooked up
yeah they were exes when season one
started like Danny was always Chuck's ex
but this makes me think that they hooked
up in recent years which wouldn't be
that crazy they're bull yeah they've
been single something in Charleston um
or maybe he gave her Cody at ten years
ago when they dated I don't know uh and
I don't think anyone's like oh she's
spreading lies like that's not the
problem here people are like how could
Austin tell ya Madison Shep's secret and
so it's not about whether it's you and I
don't even want to talk about if it's
true because it's so like invasive and
the other it doesn't really matter but
it's like okay how could often tell
Madison that but like how could Madison
it's like you tell your significant
other like everything so that doesn't
shock me as much as her actually saying
it yeah and it's like her saying and
embarrassing Danny and it's throwing her
man under the bus a big fat moving bus
and Austin like I love him like I really
I just want the best for him and like
when him and Sheppard fighting like I
know really
hurts him and that makes me really sad
yeah and I love it like he really wants
to be in a relationship and it's it's a
nice change of pace from the other guys
on the show oh great who are like Peter
Pan syndrome like just wanna go to bars
every night and that's what school makes
the show fun but it's nice to have a
different flavor when Whitney okay so I
also just caught up on this snow trip
good time we need left with Cameron
because like the night before things got
like dodgy like he is such a weenie like
I hate him so so much yeah every now and
then he's on the right side of history
like when he was younger
Ashley at the authorities really he's
just the worst the worst I don't know
what's wrong with him and all I think
about is the fact that he is a producer
on this show and this is the best he can
paint himself and at first I was like
why's Catherine sitting at the standard
table like reading an article from 2010
but it actually makes so much sense
she's like here watching all these
people get high like as if it's nothing
cuz it's not a big deal to smoke weed
but she was called a violent sociopath
back in 2015 because she smoked weed
right like she smoked weed one time and
this is what happened to her we're
smoking weed it's odd to me at this
dinner table eating me consuming it like
shoving it up our ass and it's a good
time and it's cool yeah and we're trying
to peer pressure Cameron to do it too
yeah and it's been and so you're a cool
kid I totally understood why she was
going back down memory lane and you know
what it's like everyone in this group
except for a few people like really
destroyed Katherine's life and then they
realized they were wrong and like they
said they were sorry and just like
totally moved on it's like she hasn't
moved on and they think she's being
annoying for like like staying in the
past but like they literally came so
close to ruining her life and like
really were so influential and like the
the worst part of her life and I don't I
don't know why we're just would say like
forgive Cameron like I remember I know
Cameron is I get really stuck on but
then I think like I think the worst
person aside from Thomas and all of this
for her was Whitney agreed but they were
like hooking up this summer right so if
she can forgive him and get in bed with
him then
Cameron was just you know being a
cheerleader on the sidelines and when he
was in the [ __ ] game stories also
really highlighted for me this this um
these few episodes is how much of a real
style
Kathryn brings to the show like all the
girls just literally wear the same like
jeans and boots and she brings a look to
every event and
it doesn't always hit like that making
fun of her knock well no it doesn't
always land but when it does it's
amazing she looked amazing at the fox
hunt formation she looked amazing she
nailed it and I agree like it's she
brings that Erica Jane jury like we're
taking chances but it's like all the
other housewives of beverly hills like
have their own style like I would buy
pieces off them like none of the girls
really ever dress up it just might be
like a culture thing that can Charleston
like it's much more it's like a low-key
town yeah I think that it is but she
just like really with the hair the
makeup and the outfits
honestly reminds me of Colgate and like
Kathryn yes I relate I just have always
loved her yeah we have a lot in common I
think so too
um what'd it say about style oh it's -
and her skinny outfit the red thing Real
Housewives of Orange County needs one
person with style uh I couldn't agree
more
and I'm fortunately I don't think it's
gonna be Bronwyn oh yeah and her ski
outfit agreed I mean like they were just
like laughing at her when she came in
like I just don't like that I don't like
when people make fun of other people for
taking risks um I don't think that the
core cast members we're being mean I
think they left a little entertainment
and then they were like pointing her out
on the slope so they could see her from
so far away oh when she came in for its
perm skiing I thought they were like oh
my god you look amazing
I don't know I was only asking being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I could be one side
cannot stand her evil evil [ __ ] who
makes absolutely no sense like I just I
can't stress it enough like you can be
sorry about something mean you could
still be the devil and I just I need to
cement I don't actually J country is
still the devil and all these cameos
that are coming out of her like people
are now paying her for cameos is just
giving literally three-minute tangents
about southern charm [ __ ] she she said
um she accuse someone of being gay not a
cutie like it's a bad thing but like she
just like stating facts that she knows
like someone from the cast goes to LA
and has a boyfriend or something
I wonder who I'm not gonna say because
I'm not about adding people yeah okay um
I don't even think she's sorry like her
saying that her family wouldn't talk to
her like thank you Jacob's family yes
Thank You Robbie Bobby John Jacob um but
other than that like I just think she's
trying to get back on TV and every time
her apology like doesn't go her way she
like goes back to actually see her like
getting her angry yeah her face turns
red and it's that conversation was still
weird and I'm really glad glad Katherine
didn't like blow up and make it a thing
like this girl needs to get off
I would she needs to get off now no like
honestly we don't deserve Katherine and
I think anyone who's been through what
Katherine has been through was just like
[ __ ] hate all these people like burn
it all down and she has the show like
it's her job it's her it's her income it
puts food up for that I think if she had
her way she would not be on the show
like she's mentally checked out yeah but
I think it's also good to think brought
in new cast members like Chelsea and
Iommi
who weren't around in the early days who
maybe would have decided against her but
now that she has no beef with them like
yeah they never tried to take her down
also Craig has always been on her side
Craig is a [ __ ] pea job I love Craig
me too and I don't like how people make
fun of him for his sowing like let him
do what he wants he's a nice boy yeah
and you know what he has a job like
people act like he has no job and he
just makes these pillows like the show
is your arm is a job he does a lot of
work because of it like I'm not worried
about him
I he actually I think he's in a
relationship right now oh and I hope and
so I think yes he was why don't you
think Salzer liver okay well I hope he
finds like true love I just really and I
always will have a special place in my
heart for him and a home because I love
them both but I can understand that they
weren't meant to be and they're not a
fit like now that they're out of the
relationship you could see how different
they were like they're just not the
right fit for each other yeah they like
grew apart you know and he put her on
the show so next week look insane what
happened chef brings the two girls from
the north um oh my god that really made
me annoyed like I'm having PMS with Shep
they love him as a person but what is
you doing oh man I need to ask him like
why did you do that
maybe like the producers made him I hope
and also Shep I mean Craig is the double
date it's right it's Shep and Craig I
hope also but I didn't literally just
get in the car leave I think they might
but I thought Craig was the one who said
you guys are [ __ ] Shep has a partner
in crime with him because he brought two
girls oh um is it Whitney maybe maybe
it's a girl no I don't know that's a
good question that we'll have to find
out I didn't even find those girls dears
and they're so trashy looking they can't
in Patricia's house like how dare they
and it's like Madison is a mother like
don't bring this to her I agree I love
that ass and she's so petite and small
and so cute yeah she's she's been great
like she's a really mature woman I love
the way that she carries herself also I
understand the Craig and Shay
don't approve of their relationship but
the basis of them their disapproval is
so flawed like they don't like to cheat
cheated on him in revenge for him
cheating on her it so like that they
think what she did is worse it's not
good but it's not worth it's not worse
it's much better she had a reason and it
was only one person ya know and I say
this every time you recap the show it
feels like something happened that they
are not telling us because there's no
reason for them to dislike Madison as
much as they do consider didn't said
that on when Cameron and Shep had lunch
they were like she must have something
on him they said that too
no but there's no reason for Shep and
Craig or Shep really to hit her so much
especially when we saw them getting
along on the ski trip and they actually
like could she's a cool girl she took
the gummy like she can hang she's
snowboarded maybe she'll stick up her
ass and it's like making Austin not fun
yeah but no he can't go to the bars
every night because he has a woman yeah
I guess that's technically not fun for
them totally but it really turned out to
be quite a good season of us is this is
inelia Patricia I didn't hear them say
seas but again like season finale
thought and they film their reunion last
week but I think it's too quick of a
turnaround yeah maybe there's a few more
episodes yeah Ashley comes in next week
and starts screaming at Patricia she's
not she is nuts
but other than that great season I agree
I'm turning on I mean I've turned on
Eliza Thornberry like she's been like
watching her work at the hotel I like
what she brings to the show except what
also what she brings to the show is
actually but one like that keeps the
show going because right now everyone's
getting along in this Madison story line
cannot hold up the whole season and to
like I really think she's trying to
she's struggling with being a forgiving
person
like when her she started reading the
Bible on her phone I was like okay yeah
it's forgiven seven times so we have to
go through the seven times
damn okay well that's all she wrote Oh
tomorrow's episode is gonna be podcast
only because our studio is closed by 10
o'clock tomorrow maybe even earlier it's
been a wonderful week hanging out with
you guys and nice to be back back in the
swing of things and that's all she wrote
have an amazing day think if you're
listening to the morning toast the
Millennial morning show where we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so feel free to give
this video a thumbs up subscribe if
you're watching but if you listen as a
podcast on iTunes Spotify States your
public radio anywhere you can listen to
podcasts they'll be described there too
scribe subscribe there to give us five
stars tell us how beautiful we are
and we'll see tomorrow bye see ya bye
you